this movie takes place in the mid-90s
I'm gonna assume it's 1997 cuz there's a
scene where he and his brother are
playing PlayStation 1 but they're
playing it with the analog controller
the analog controller came out in 1997
if they wanted to take place before 1997
gotta go old-school dude but any later
than 1997 would be 1998 in which cases
movie probably should have been called
late 90s so 97 it is
[Music]
mid-90s so mid-90s is written and
directed by Jonah Hill it's really the
store of a kid hanging out in the mid
90s kids before social media you get to
see what kids did with their time which
is video games movies playing in the
woods and making forts or skateboarding
and that's what these kids in here did
it follows this young kid it has a
pretty shitty home life I guess brother
beats him up doesn't just we're not
talking brother wrestling this kid
really gets pummeled by his brother
literally abused so he starts hanging
out with these kids who hang out in a
skateboard shop they go skateboarding so
he takes up skateboarding himself he
hangs out with them he gets the name
sunburnt which I thought was great
because I gave everybody a nickname
couldn't talk to a girl to save my life
but nicknames for days it's really this
is what it is it's a really simple story
but a very sweet story about hanging out
in the mid 90s and really the crews a
crew of no but I'd say I'll do a fine
job some do better than others but in
the end you just fall into the purity of
it like I was never a skater in the 90s
but some of the scenarios I completely
recognized there see where he's in his
bedroom with his girl he doesn't know
what to do I was there I had no idea
what to do in fact that kid got farther
than me I just sat there and froze up
whatever at other things on my mind like
Final Fantasy 7 wasn't gonna beat itself
but it was a neat look into that world I
got really nostalgic although like his
friends I I didn't hang out with that
crowd that's the thing it's like you
don't have to this friends circle
hanging out these friends hanging out
there's friends hanging out feels like
friends hanging out but really it's an
interesting to look into that world
there's a peek behind the curtain that
asks the question who are those kids who
are they inside like what's their home
life life like it's so easy to see a
certain group of kids and be like either
huddle up to no good was actually an
awesome moment or the kids moms just
freaking out like I look like gang
members but it's like they're way better
for your kid then your other son his
brother is but it just shows so often
parents it's hard for them to reflect
into the household it's easy to be like
oh there's not a problem here but
sometimes there is and I got to give the
movie props for sticking to the times
this movie completely felt like it was
made about and made in the 90s it's
filmed with 4 by 3 aspect ratio it looks
like this it's not like a found footage
movie or anything like that it just
makes it feel a little more of the 90s
and I know 90s movies had scope and flat
aspect ratio back then I know widescreen
existed but it's not supposed to feel
super high budget imagine a super small
indie movie of the 90s would look a lot
like this or in black-and-white
whichever one the movie does have some
language representative of the time that
some people in 2018 might not like like
example if they see something they don't
like if something is lame they don't say
lame they say that's gay which was
common language of youth in
it doesn't stop there there are harsher
terms that they use also that were also
common language back there I only bring
it up because I heard there's some heat
and backlash on the movie for that is
because the usage of those terms is more
recent than the 90 is not like those
terms just died in the 90s not like the
turn of the millennium like all right
we're not using those jokes anymore
those kind of jokes in terms were used
in television shows movies I felt there
recently actually comparatively recently
someone can make a movie called the
2000s and you could use a lot of the
same terminology in that movie I
personally saw that kind of language
being used in this movie as the artists
representing the time the movie does end
a bit abruptly it's not a long movie
it's just shy of an hour and a half long
when the movie ends you're like so it's
over I guess what is this a Sopranos
finale right if there's a bit of an arc
you see but there's one part where I
feel like more consequences should have
happened just like something happens and
essentially they'll just dodge a bullet
feel like the gods demand to just
sacrifice there they can get one because
in the end mid-90s I really enjoyed I
don't know if it's because I was alive
in the mid 90s and is that a nostalgic
part of my brain going oh yeah I totally
remember this world I just want to
escape 2018 that much I genuinely
believe it's a sweet film an interesting
story about a kid a kid trying to find a
family because his family life sucks and
I'll say it mid-90s was a really good
time to welcome home with flowers
whereas so mid-90s have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here just anymore
[Music]